get clear on what you want what do you
want make it super clear you can't just
want a better life what does that look
like get super clear on what it is that
you are going after write it down one
sentence make it clear for yourself make
it clear for the people around you make
it clear for anybody who comes in
contact with you say hey what do you
want this this is what I want I have
absolute focus and when people look at
you and say you're never going to do
that look at where you're coming from
that's okay because you have direction
right the world gets out of the way for
the person who knows what they want you
need to get clear on what you want get
it down to one sentence need motivation
watch the top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Nina Carmichael and we made these
videos because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push especially around yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband ever in
Carmichael and our take on his top 10
rules for Success enjoy bye
rule number two find your path my
biggest fear is disappointing people my
biggest fear is I'm gonna let people
down you're going to watch my my thing
my video my interview and feel like it
was a waste your time that Matthew would
feel it's a waste of time that you feel
it's a waste of time that's always my
biggest fear is that I'll still show up
but it's going to be a disappointment to
people
and so my strategy used to be prepare
prepare prepare prepare prepare prepare
prepare prepare
prepare like crazy that used to be my
strategies always prepare over prepare
have everything super prepared
and
what ended up happening was a solid B
interview
because I just asked the questions that
were on my list
there was there was nothing risky
but it wasn't a great interview
and I was just asking typical questions
um I didn't offend anybody
but it was never anything great
and so what I had to learn to adjust and
this is something that um Dr Tess helped
a lot with was figuring out you know
what all I need to do is find the one
angle what's my one angle what's the One
path what's the one series of questions
that I want to ask and then pull on that
thread and trust that my curiosity will
take over
so
with Matthew
he wanted to promote his book I didn't
have enough time to read the book fully
before I came in I'm a super slow reader
and I got it shortly before the
interview I'm a visual learner so what I
did was I watched his other interviews I
went to the other interviews that he had
talking about the book
and what I did was I thought okay what
would I ask that's different from these
guys or what's the question that they
didn't ask as a follow-up like oh that's
a good line of thinking what's the
follow-up oh did I wish they asked that
question and I made a note of this is
the question I want to ask and the thing
that
caught my attention the most was him
talking about when he took his uh
sabbatical from acting
um it wasn't it was kind of a force
sabbatical he didn't want to do romantic
comedies anymore and ended up going 20
months without acting
and he considered going to other careers
the job that he was looking at as other
careers they were see if I can remember
there was
a grade four teacher there was
a high school football coach there was a
musical conductor Orchestra conduct an
orchestra there was be an animal
Wilderness guide
and I think there was one more
and I asked him these things
they all seem to have teaching in common
whether they're teaching kids or adults
it's a wide range of different
potentials but they're all teaching if
you're a conductor you're still teaching
professionals if you're the animal the
guy you're teaching about the animals
like where does that threat come from
and he said I never thought about that
he didn't quite know how to answer that
question and at the very end of our
interview 20 minutes later he thanked me
for
bringing that up and he's gonna go keep
on thinking about this whole teaching
angle and why that's in him and where it
comes from I'm gonna keep thinking about
this common denominator of me wanting to
be a teacher thank you that's a much
better interview
as asking a question that I don't know
what the answer is going to be
and it's my genuine curiosity
and so there's always that line in
between of
the thing that you are preparing for and
preparing for preparing for to then give
you the freedom to be open
and curious
I do a lot of work with Tony Robbins
agency
his PR agency and and we brought a whole
bunch of different people on my channel
to do different interviews with and one
of the things that the the head person
there
always says about me which is super
humbling is just the Curiosity and
energy that I have to show up for the
interviews and it's shocking to hear
that because it's like I don't I never
thought of myself as a great interviewer
but all I have to do when I'm preparing
is find the angle like what do I
actually why am I genuine and energetic
because I actually care about this thing
from them I have to find their story and
research them enough to know the angle
that I want to use to find the thread to
pull on
and then I just let go and trust that
I'm going to do a good job rule number
three be consistent your success is
habits what you do on a regular basis is
what you're going to accomplish you can
do the chocolate bar and be on a diet
and not get fat but if you're in the
chocolate bar every day you're gonna get
fat you're not on a diet anymore
similarly if you eat salad once a week
it's not enough right you are what you
consistently do your success comes from
doing habits and entrepreneurs are
typically great starters but not great
at being consistent and that's the
problem
working your face off for for 48 hour
stretch isn't going to do anything for
you it's every single day working even
if it's only an hour a day that dream
that you have that business that you
wanted to start that business that you
want to take to the next level it could
be there it could have been there
already it could have been there already
the problem is you've been sitting on
that idea for three months six months
four years without doing enough on it
little tiny starts it's not enough every
day I'm talking every single day making
progress towards you actually
accomplishing that thing you want that
life you have to do it every day rule
number four focus on service focus on
service will immediately
reduce anxiety reduce your stress and
reduce the lack of self-love that you're
feeling
okay so that's service great but how do
I serve whom do I serve well that comes
back to your why
is your purpose your purpose comes from
your pain the people who you'll love
helping
for the rest of your life
are the people who currently are who you
used to be
think about who you used to be think
about what you used to struggle with the
demons that you were fighting the hole
that you are in you are much better now
than who you used to be think about your
most painful moment not physical pain of
breaking I broke my neck in two spots
that was my most physical pain but not
that emotional pain when did you feel
the most worthless when did you feel the
most worthless as a human being when was
that for you
and then recognize that there are
millions of people right now who are
struggling with the same thing they feel
worthless they feel the same
worthlessness that you felt they're
struggling with the exact same thing
exact same thing that you're that you
struggled with right now they're in the
depths of it you've come out you're not
where you want to be you still got a lot
of growth left you still want to improve
you still want to do a lot more
but you're way better off compared to
who you used to be
and sometimes it helps to just think
about who you were 10 years ago five
years ago or maybe you already know the
moment in your in your life that was the
worst for you there are millions of
people who are suffering with that same
thing right now
your path is to help them
your path is to show them hope your path
is to give them the strategies to get
out
because a lot of them they're so low
they're so negative they're so hopeless
that they won't listen to an Evan
Carmichael or Marie forleo or Tony
Robbins
former you didn't want to listen to an
Evan Carmichael okay
motivational self-help BS
he doesn't understand me
but you know what to listen to you
they'll listen to you because you are
one of them
because you know exactly what they're
dealing with exactly what they're going
through and exactly how to get out of it
because you tried a million different
things a million different things how
many things did you try to get out of
the hole that you were in how many
things how many times did you try how
many times did you get up and fail and
get back up and fail and try a new thing
that was supposed to be the answer and
then failed didn't work again and almost
give up and almost give up and almost
give up and then you finally found
something one thing that maybe didn't
even seem like a big thing and it and it
worked
holy cow this is working I'm getting
momentum I I'm starting to change and
starting to see results
and now you're here congratulations
you made it
you are an impossibility right you being
here is impossible to former you you 10
years ago look to where you are right
now it's like that's not possible I
won't be there I can't do that it's an
impossibility
but you did it
[Music]
and so that's your job is to go back and
show all the people who currently are
who you used to be that it is possible
that they can do it that you're just
like them
that you were them that you might have
struck struggled and suffered struffled
is that the combination struggled and
suffered is truffled you struffled
worse than them
worse than them and yet and yet here you
are you made it
helping somebody
Who currently is who you used to be
that's the game that's the juice that'll
fill you up for the rest of your life
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five find a worthy
challenge one of my greatest fears right
now of all time actually is
disappointing people I hate
disappointing people it's my greatest
fear of all time I don't want to
disappoint people the idea
the idea is is life-shattering to me I
hate that I hate wasting people's time
and so I'm on this tour right now I'm in
San Francisco I'm doing 23 cities over
90 days
and I'm scared
because I'm scared I'm going to
disappoint people and it's not just one
event I get to get up every four days
and potentially disappoint people again
your heart goes boom boom boom boom boom
you have to do it and now just the fact
that I'm out doing it regardless of if
we have amazing results or not just me
doing it just me trying it makes me feel
great about myself
and so you need to find the same thing
for you what is the challenge that is
worthy of you that if you got up and
every day tried your best you would
eventually win at it that you're not
going to tie yourself respect to you
crushing it immediately if you get a
victory right away you should have
started it three years ago if you get up
and you make a YouTube video and your
first one and it's amazing you actually
suck like you should have started that
video three years ago you're supposed to
suck at the beginning you always suck at
the beginning any new skill that you
want to learn you're not going to be
very good at it at the start that's how
it's supposed to work but if you tie
your self-respect your self-worth your
self-love to you getting up and doing
work every single day that makes you
proud that says I am proud of myself
today for the effort that I put in I
guarantee you you will not just love
yourself you will produce amazing things
for yourself for your family and for the
world rule number six just try for too
many of us myself included
uh we don't play enough we don't have
enough fun we don't we don't take the
risk that's in our head and one of the
things that I'm constantly trying to
work on is that idea to action right
that when I come up with an idea I'm
going to do something about it and it's
especially hard when other people are
involved it's especially hard in an
interview
I'm sitting there talking to Matthew
asking him about his career we spent an
hour together and we'll link up the
video at the end of this video
and as ideas come to me
they constantly judge the question like
oh I don't know should I ask that
question should I ask that question
about is it gonna is is that a good
question is it going to be offended by
the question should I keep pulling on
this thread is that a good question
asked or should I move on to the next
topic it's this constant kind of track
going on the back of my head and what
I've learned to do more and more and
more and more is just trust
the question
I came to you for a reason it may not
make sense
but trust the question
if the intention is good
right the intention isn't to make him
look bad or anybody else look bad right
the intention is good the tension is
positive this question came to me for a
reason
trust him do something on it I think
that's one of the biggest things that
holds people back is you get these ideas
in the moment
and you don't trust it
and then it it maybe disappears or maybe
you look back and say I wish I did that
this is why I started my first business
I actually didn't think it was going to
work out when I was 19 I had to choose
between making 300 bucks a month and
owning 30 in this company or making six
figures at my what I thought was my
dream job Banking and traveling around
the world
I didn't think or no I wasn't like yes
his business is for sure going to work
out this business is for sure gonna be
my big exit I'm gonna make tons of money
it was more I didn't want to regret not
knowing that even if the most likely
scenario was failure I still had to know
and I would rather no one fail than not
know
and what I've learned to do over the
past 20 years I guess and still continue
you know I still want to get a question
in my head or an idea in my head there's
still a moment of hesitation and that's
what I'm constantly working on
getting rid of
that idea to action immediate faster
faster faster faster but this idea came
to me for a reason
that I have to at least try that I have
to at least take the first two percent
the two percent difference right stop
planning for 100 and just take action on
the first two percent then have to try
that I have to at least get a taste of
it instead of prejudging it instead of
telling myself that it's not going to
work out
that as long as the intention is good
and the intention is to serve and to
help
that I need to try
you can always
back up from it right like if I asked a
question that offended him I could
always explain where I came from I can
always explain the intent the worst case
scenario isn't that bad
it's not that bad you can almost always
make it up to somebody
versus the upside of actually doing it
and it works out and what you find is if
you continue to listen to that intuition
if you continue to Listen to Your Big
Ideas if you continue to ask the
questions that you want to ask do the
thing that you want to do
you'll find a much happier life
you'll find a much more impactful life a
much more purposeful life
and I think that's the life you deserve
rule number seven focus on your strength
let's look at social media great pick
one
pick one just pick one and crush it
whether it's Twitter or Instagram or
YouTube whatever you think has the best
combination of what you're good at you
know if you like making videos YouTube's
a great place to be if you like writing
you can go on Twitter or medium right
pick the one platform and then spend
your time focused on that because if I
look at most of people's content
you look at your own content look at
what you're posting across these
platforms are you proud of it would you
follow you
probably not for too many people so stop
wasting time posting mediocre garbage
and post quality in one spot and start
to win there and then leverage it and
then build a team and then expand same
thing with products and services and
business lines you can't do a great job
servicing your customers investing back
to research Development coming up with
new white you can't you can't not if
you're doing 18 businesses at the same
time
I had a woman come out to my uh Workshop
when I was doing a tour
and this was her issue she was in real
estate and she was in network marketing
and she was in five different business
lines she said well I need to diversify
diversify what you don't have anything
yet you're diversifying yourself out of
a life
out of an income out of the business
where if you just had one super strong
pillar that then won
you'll win now the argument for
diversification is well if one thing
promos you got something else great but
here's what people are missing if
YouTube crumbles I'll take my skill set
and go somewhere else if my business
crumbles I'm still me I'll take my skill
set and move somewhere else look at Jake
Paul and Logan Paul they were on Vine
they crushed it on Vine top people on
Vine Vine closes down right almost
overnight closes down great they have a
skill set they come to YouTube and blow
up I get millions of subscribers
if YouTube goes away
for me my skill set is applicable to
wherever people are going to watch video
content next if your business goes away
the skills that you've learned will go
somewhere else
you haven't lost you haven't forgotten
how to do your thing
diversification is only important when
you don't know what you're doing
that's why it's a great investment
strategy rule number eight model success
the fastest path for you to get to
success you're after is to model success
the idea here is simple you find people
who have already done the thing that you
want to do learn from them understand
what they did to get there and then try
on their hat right see what worked for
them and apply it to your business this
is what worked for me this is what saved
my company build States saved my first
company even though I've never met him I
haven't yet we're gonna make it happen
hopefully hopefully hopefully soon
I was struggling I had a upstart
software company that wasn't making
money and I quit on my business partner
and I woke up the next day and said I
need to find a way to make this happen
like I can't quit on this too soon
because I'm going to regret it if I
don't keep going and so I said who has
done this before who's done this and I
thought of Bill Gates was the first
person that came to mind was Bill Gates
I looked at his story and how did he
build Microsoft was through Partnerships
and so I started making Partnerships in
my business I had nothing else to lose I
was already at rock bottom right I
already quit on my partner it was
hopeless so let's just give this a shot
and within I don't know a couple months
maybe even sooner I landed my first
partnership deal for thirteen and a half
thousand dollars and at the time guys I
was making 300 bucks a month so that
money meant the world to me like that
was that was bank and and more important
than that it it gave me hope you know
like this could happen this this
business could actually work and it gave
me a model to then go and do it again
and again and again and ever since then
whenever I don't know what to do on
model success I find someone who's done
it and I try to apply their strategies
and make it work for me but this is the
important thing not every strategy is
going to work the same way for them as
it did for you
so maybe waking up early is your ticket
maybe waking up later is going to be
your ticket it's people who've done both
which is the one that's gonna work for
you you won't know by sitting on the
couch and thinking about it the best
thing you can do is just go and try you
try on their hat right Bill Gates did
this Dan Lok does this Bruce Lee does
this awesome try it rule number nine
shift your perspective if you're doing
something big you're gonna get haters if
you're doing something that nobody has
done before that is game changing that
is breaking the status quo you're gonna
have people who want to hold on to the
Past want to hold on to their way of
thinking they don't want to see other
people become successful and so they're
going to hate on you the more you're off
being bold and trying to do something
different creative new could be on a
global level or could just be doing
something that's not normal in your
family right then you're gonna have
haters you're gonna have the people who
are against it because they stand for
the status quo the more you stand for
something big you understand that you
stand against something else and the
people who like that stuff even if it's
a negative way of life they're gonna to
fight for it and they're gonna see you
as the enemy and attack you what's the
alternative the alternative is to live
such a small life to never take any
risks to only do what everybody else
tells you to do to never have a life of
your own so that you don't risk
offending everybody that's a pretty
crappy life and it's not that you're out
there intentionally trying to hurt
people it's not saying look at me and
how great I am and you suck right it's
not it's not putting that kind of vibe
out but just by you being you and trying
to do something big and bold is going to
upset people not because they actually
hate you it's because they hate
something within themselves I look at my
message and believe it's powerful it's
positive it's uplifting how do you hate
on believe how do you hate on somebody
who's encouraging people to untap their
potential right but people do I think it
takes some getting used to and I think
the the the more you are out there the
more content you're creating the bigger
your company grows and the bigger that
you get and the more of an audience that
you build up of customers or people
following you
then the more you're gonna be seen as a
target for a certain select group of
people and I used to in the early days
of me having my YouTube channel I used
to take it personally I used to be
really upset when somebody left a
negative comment I used to you know only
see that one negative comment and ignore
the 99 positive ones I used to try to
fight with that person and explain
myself or try to change them and try to
bring them around and in that process
sometimes it worked sometimes I was able
to explain my perspective and bring them
around to to my point of view or at
least get some kind of common ground
and sometimes it did sometimes I
couldn't change them the thing is it
just takes so much time and effort like
is it worth spending all that time on
that one person you're trying to make a
positive impact with and maybe ship them
a little bit versus investing that time
into the 99 other people who love you
who care about you who who are really
consuming that you can go a lot further
with and it sounds crass and it sounds
it sounds really terrible to say don't
spend time on those people ignore them
but the fact is they steal so much of
your energy and it's always an
opportunity cost like that time spent if
I can help 20 people achieve amazing
results or try to help one person
achieve subpar results that's just a
little bit better than what they were
getting before what's the best use of my
time and so that was one thing that
really helped me
shift away from trying to fight with
them from trying to change them and just
leave them leave them there leave those
comments up
but it still hurt right like it still
hurt like ah it stings that comment
the thing that really shifted it forward
for me of not caring of putting things
in perspective was me trying to put
myself in their shoes imagine somebody
who's who's gets off by going to a
YouTube channel or going to a customer
site or going to an e-commerce site or
whatever it is and leaving a negative
comment leaving like a hateful negative
comment not not a constructive criticism
not a Evan you know your hoodie is off
today you know get the lint roller or
something right like constructive
criticism just just nasty hate stuff
what would motivate somebody to do that
like imagine that that this is how they
get off this is how they are half like
how crafty a life do you have to have
that this is the thing that makes you
come alive and feel happy
and just by shifting that perspective
now when I see a negative comment like
that it honestly just makes me feel
sorry for that person that this is the
only way to get attention this is this
is the best part of their day this is
the high life is being able to come and
leave hate comments their entire life
must really suck and uh that shift
allows me not to care rule number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
clip stop living in the past I live 85
in the present in the moment 15 in the
future and zero percent in the past 85
in the present in the moment zero
percent in the past and 15 in the future
I think it's really important I think
most people's perspectives are messed up
I think most people live in flux between
in the past and in the future
and very little time in the present
think about it think about what you're
doing today what am I doing right now
I'm filming this video for you guys what
am I focused on you guys what am I doing
next I have no idea where did I just
come from no idea I'm here I'm here
focus on you helping make content for
you and hopefully spending a message
that means something today as part of
your morning routine hey happy morning
good morning good to be here most people
are stuck in the past and you're
reliving yesterday and last week and
last year and the last decade thinking
about all the mistakes you've made and
every everything that you did wrong and
why you're not good enough and what you
would do to go back and tell yourself to
do the different and how you missed some
big opportunity and how everything is
your parents fault how does that serve
you I mean awareness is great
even in my in my book built to serve we
go through the who I have process uh
figuring out who you are right uh your
why your purpose which comes from your
pain and then how you got out of it it
serves as tools to help you move forward
but it's living in the past just to get
the awareness to make better decisions
in the present in the future not just
living in the past to live there in the
past and soul can be depressed people
who live in the past are usually upset
they're angry they're they're unhappy
they're depressed because life used to
be so good and now life sucks
I want to spend zero time living in the
past did I make mistakes sure did I
learn from them yeah can I go back and
change yesterday nope so I'm not going
to do it I'm not going to think about it
stop thinking about it let's talk about
living in the future
living in the future depends on the
source depends on if it's coming from a
good place or a bad place most people
who are living in the future are doing
it from a place of insecurity what if it
doesn't work out what if I don't make it
all the things that could go wrong and
trying to plan the perfect plan and so
you're a perfectionist because you're
worried about
people's opinion of what you're going to
say what you're going to do you're
worried that people will see it and
judge you you're worried that people
won't see it and that you're not good
enough it's just constantly living in
this future fear that maybe happens
maybe doesn't happen but it prevents
action
the more you're living in future fear
that prevents current action
where it's healthy is to think about
what you could build the possibility
what you want to make what you want to
create
be the change you want to see in the
world
one of my favorite quotes Mahatma Gandhi
if you're not happy with something
you're not happy with a situation you
fix it that's why entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the problems
not as much as there's government and
big business I think it's entrepreneurs
it's us we're going to solve all the
world's problems because we see a
problem and we want to fix it we want to
solve it that's what we do that's the
most exciting part of being an
entrepreneur is that you're not waking
up and driving to some job that you hate
where the work you're doing does not
matter has no meaning and instead you
get to do something that is actually
going to touch somebody's life and that
is Meaningful to you right you get the
pick you get to decide you get to choose
and we're trying to make the world a
better place we're going to make money
doing it too but Mission first purpose
first and then making money along the
way in service of others and it's in
that combination of what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
that you have a successful business
part of that then becomes being a leader
as well and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle with being the
leader because at the beginning
we are just managing ourselves and
that's hard enough right it's like have
you had a hard time managing yourself
have you had a hard time sticking to
your routines and keeping to your
motivation and staying strong and the
things that you say you're going to do
like self-management self-leadership is
hard enough now we're going to go off
and lead other people as well
and where do we learn about leadership
we don't go to school for this we don't
have programs we don't probably have
great mentors to help us if you had jobs
in the past or maybe you're at a job
right now you probably don't have the
greatest leaders around you most people
suck at it but it doesn't have to be
extremely difficult
and it took me a long time to get used
to it and get better at it and I'm still
learning and improving we've got almost
40 people on the team now and can people
ask me what's my definition my
definition of leadership it's I want
people to win more than I want them to
win with me
and so the key becomes
wanting the humans that are on your team
to win as humans
more than you want them to win with you
that you can have this little
disconnection obviously they have to do
the work if they're going to work with
you but sometimes the best thing for
them to do is to move on
not because they're not doing their job
but because it's the best thing for them
and so when I connect with the people on
my team it's always trying to figure out
where do they want to go what do they
want to learn what do they what do they
want to improve on and I see everybody
as running parallel paths with me so the
people around you the people even us
right now what we're doing right now
this is a parallel path you've decided
to watch this video I decided to record
this video and we're sharing this moment
in time and maybe you never watch
another Urban Carmichael video again
maybe you end up watching all my videos
and we end up being Partners on some
future business who knows you know we
haven't seen you every day in the future
but as of right now we're on this
parallel path together and
when somebody's with you walking down
that parallel path
the goal of a great leader I think
should be to try to make that person
leave better than how they came in
right have you ever heard the expression
um my grandfather used to tell me about
you know when you go to a hotel
or you go to a new city or you go to a
new event they always try to leave the
place better than when you came
you know and hopefully that's our goal
for life you know in this life we try to
leave
the world a little better than how it
was when we came in
and so if you take that approach to
leadership that when you're with the
people on your team
and maybe it's for a week on some really
short internship maybe it's for a year
maybe it's for five years ten years
maybe it's their entire life with you
that they have left a little bit better
than when they came in because they got
to hang around you and not taking it as
an ego play like I'm gonna make this
person's life better because I am so
amazing it's more out of care
genuine care
for the people on your team and I think
when we're first hiring
we suck at it
most entrepreneurs suck at hiring most
entrepreneurs their first employee is
not with them you know a year two years
three years later because they hired the
wrong person they have no idea how to
manage that person it's not that that
person sucks it's more that you know you
don't have the skill set we don't have
the skill sets at the beginning to know
how to even find the right person let
alone manage them and so
you know we that's the skill that we
have to develop but I think it just
starts with genuinely caring about the
people on your team that yes they have
to get the work done right there's a job
that has to get done but how we often
think about it is more from a selfish
perspective as I need to get this stuff
off my plate right you're overloaded
with work right who's over are you
overloaded with work we're overloaded
with work
so I gotta hire somebody to take this
off my plate so I don't have to deal
with that ever again and it frees up my
time to go and do other stuff
right so familiar listen at the
beginning when you bring on team it
takes more time
it takes more time than it frees up
because you have to train them you have
to listen to them you have to care for
them you have to answer their questions
if you treat them like a robot or a
monkey
they're not going to stick with you
you're going to constantly be hiring and
firing and hiring firing are you going
to be massively frustrated and
overwhelmed and a lot of a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck in that cycle
where has this happened to you you hire
somebody you know looks great on paper
you're so excited for it to go and then
it doesn't work out a couple months
later and then you decide you know what
I'm just gonna do it all myself right I
know I can get it done I'm just gonna do
it all myself does that happen to you
that is not the path to building a
movement you know you can have a great
little solo business for yourself but
that's not how you change the world
that's not how you realize your
potential it's not how you have the
impact that you know you're capable of
having you know you have to have people
around you if you've got a big mission
if you don't have a big mission that's
just it's just you cool go for it but if
you've got a big mission then it needs
to be team and that becomes a skill set
that you have to pick up and learn
and so leadership for me is again caring
about people as humans more than caring
about them winning with you it's about
discovering what they want to learn and
grow and improve at and you being a
vehicle to help them do that and it's
surprising how often you can find things
that support them and support you not
all the time I remember having one guy
in my team who his dream was to be a
baker
like well I I don't have an interest in
opening up a bake shop right but
ultimately you should you should leave
us and go do your passion because
because I can't help you inside of this
job
until I open a bake shop that can really
support you in what you want to do and
so even though he wanted to stay he was
staying more out of fear and insecurity
than actually doing something he was
deeply passionate about so I gave him
till the end of the year if it was you
know summer give him to the end of the
year to okay you're as of the end of the
year you you're out and you have to go
find a job I love you but you have to go
find something that is
in line with your dream because you
staying here is is safe and it's
actually squashing your dreams
you have to go do your thing and so you
know you had to go and move on it was
appreciative for it and giving him time
not like okay you're fired next week
and then you have other people though
and usually you can find something
inside of what they care about so the
the amount of people who I've met on my
team who then they want to learn graphic
design or they want to learn Photoshop
or they want to learn uh copywriting or
they want to learn how to come up with
good titles or they want to learn
better communication skills or they want
to learn they have their lists of like
the things that they want to learn
it's like cool as long as there's
something that we've got
that can help you with that some kind of
program some project something that can
also bring value to the company then
let's do it because when people are
working on the things that they feel
like they're growing in and they're
learning in
they're gonna
it's just a good thing to do because
it's it's from the heart you know and
when they feel connected to your heart
everybody's happier and more productive
but it's also just good business
strategy if you want to just put your
Exo business strategy hat on it's it's
great this is how Karma becomes
practical if somebody's engaged and they
feel like they're learning and they're
growing and they're improving you're
going to get the best of them versus you
have to feel bored and stuck and
learning nothing new right that's what
most people do in their jobs and
honestly the bar for leadership is so
low
it's so low most people wake up and
drive to that job that they hate so all
you have to do to be honest to be their
best boss is probably just to not be a
bad boss you don't have to be a great
boss you just have to not not be a bad
boss you need to treat somebody like a
normal human being and actually have a
little bit of care and compassion and
curiosity to see them win in life
you do that you're already probably
their best boss of all time I think
that's a pretty low standard but it's a
great starting point
to then be able to say hey no I want I
want this person to have come out of my
organization whether that's in a month
or year 10 years from now
a better human because they were with us
and it's totally possible
it's just a mindset shift
that
these people are on your team
because they have something to prove as
well and they want to learn and it's not
just about you saving your time and
dumping stuff off of your plate and
giving it to somebody else so it can be
all delegated away
it's that you are a leader
and you care about people and you want
to see them win and you're responsible
for making sure that they get pushed
outside their comfort zone
you got a big mission inside you
a huge mission
and you can't do this alone
and you may not have the skills yet
to be the leader that you want to be
maybe not yet
but you've got a big heart
and honestly
that's the biggest skill that you ever
need most people sleepwalk through life
because they don't love what they're
doing you wake up and you don't love
what you're doing you feel like it
doesn't matter or you feel like nobody
will care if you show up or you don't
and if if that was your day
if you today felt like you know what it
doesn't matter I show up I don't show up
I make I don't make nobody's gonna
really care if that was not just today
but tomorrow the next day the next day
the next day if that was every day of
your life how sad would your life be
this is why we have so much anxiety and
depression and suicide is because people
feel like they don't matter and we want
to matter to others is wired into us we
want to feel like we are important we
want to feel like what we're going to do
today is going to create some kind of
meaning and impact on somebody else's
life we are built to serve you want to
help it's not enough to want to do
something just for yourself you want to
feel like you matter to somebody else
today
most people sleepwalk through their
lives
never feeling like they meant anything
to anybody especially in their work
and it's why a lot of people default to
entrepreneurship to try to say well
here's my chance to be to be My Own Boss
use my chance to live my own life here's
my chance to do something that matters
without just being some Cog in a
corporate machine
but unless you connect the work that
you're doing to serving and helping
other people you still won't feel great
when I first started in my business it
was really really hard
both businesses but the business where I
helped Inspire entrepreneurs and I got
asked to speak and I remember just
loving the speaking part and at the time
I was doing a speaking gig a month or so
and just wasn't getting enough feedback
I'd go and it'd be amazing I'd be
certain so nervous and so scared to get
up on stage
but then the end would be so amazing and
to see that you helped somebody you know
how good it feels to help somebody
you know how good it feels to make
somebody smile or laugh or cry or
for them just to say thank you
you know you know you know how good it
feels when somebody says thank you for
what you've done for me today
that is more valuable than whatever
they're paying you for your product or
service right we all want that that's
the good thing to get addicted to so
when I first started speaking and
helping
I I was getting that once a month and
doing a speaking gig but then I wasn't
feeling it throughout the month this is
the hard part of being an entrepreneur
especially at the beginning when you
don't have enough feedback you're not
feeling valuable it takes too long to
get your product to service or service
to Market to see the at the action that
your customers are getting from it
and so I had to remind myself of what I
was doing I had to remind myself I made
a PowerPoint file where I looked at my
comments every day the feedback that I
was getting even though it was for three
weeks ago I still looked at the feedback
again to remind myself of what I was
doing was important when I started my
YouTube Channel I didn't get any
feedback I wasn't getting any comments
right my first video took a year to get
three comments and it was my mom my
older sister and then some random guy so
I wasn't getting a lot of feedback
but I still would look at my comments
every day just to feel like hey this is
important like if I got one comment a
week I'd be so happy it's like yeah I
see that person I helped that person
I gotta keep going I got to keep making
got to keep creating
and even to this day it still is among
the most important things that I do
I'm I'm pretty in love with Discord
right now I created my own Discord
server you can join believe Nation it's
Evan carmichael.biz it's free and I'm in
there every morning right now
just helping and it's one of my go-to's
right now for how I start my day start
my day I look at my calendar I set my
intention for the day and then I'll go
to my Discord server and start helping
people
because
having a million views on a video or
however many subscribers or whatever it
does not feel as good as
going into Discord server and helping
one person believing themselves a little
bit more
so you have to figure out a way to make
it
not a Sleepwalk every day
to make it feel like you're doing
something that matters that you matter
that today is going to matter that you
show up in a way that matters so let me
break down a couple things that I think
can help number one is the big picture
has to matter
this is why people struggle in jobs
because you feel like nobody cares right
this job doesn't mean anything
the company doesn't care if I'm here or
not even the company's Mission isn't
that important you don't feel connected
to what you're doing every day you have
to feel connected to the mission
if you're an entrepreneur it's a lot
easier but you have to be doing work
that you actually think matters a lot of
entrepreneurs start a company just
trying to make money you're just trying
to pay the bills you're just trying to
make some cash you're just trying to
look at the hot opportunity and if you
can't connect to the reason why you're
doing it the mission you won't win the
number one rule for success is you have
to love the thing that you're doing if
you're doing it just to make money
making money is important it is
important you have to do it it needs to
be in your top five but it can't be
number one what is number one
you have to design your business that
you feel like you're on a mission that
you're here to serve that you're doing
some kind of good that you you may not
be there yet you may not be
accomplishing anything close to it yet
but it's the goal it's the mission that
you're trying to go off and achieve
so number one is you have to feel like
on a big scale on a macro scale that if
it all plays out this is going to really
really really really really matter to
you but to other people as well
two is
the micro winds have to be there you
know it's the it's the Big Y and the
little y so the first one is the Big Y
the big why what am I trying to
accomplish the second one is a little
wide little Y is the daily little ones
you could be
inspired by your Big Y
it could be driving you it could be
fulfilling you but
there will be many days where the Big Y
is not enough
there'll be many days where you feel
like you can't do that big why that who
are you to think you could do that crazy
big thing that it's never going to
happen that you're not going to make it
that it's just it's just not worth it
there'll be many days where you feel
like that
especially when you don't see any
tractional momentum happening that's
what the little y's come into place the
little Y is the daily little feeling
like hey I did something to help one
person I may not be able to impact the
world today I may not be having a
life-changing product or service or
launch or video or whatever but I can
help one person today that's why I go to
the Discord every morning that's why I'm
in my comments every day because
my big why is to change the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I'm never going to do
it and there are days where that feels
way too big and too scary I channel that
into this like this video I want this
video to matter I'm sitting here in the
parking lot in my car while Nina's at a
a pet store getting stuff for the dogs
right I'm just talking to my cell phone
but I want this video to matter I want
this video to touch you I want this
video to have some kind of meaningful
impact that maybe this is the day the
way that I say the words the energy that
I show up with maybe maybe just maybe
this is a day that you finally go off
and make some kind of change maybe today
is the day that's my sincere hope
and
I need to still feel like I'm touching
somebody that talking to my phone is not
enough so going to the Discord server
talking to people encouraging them
giving them some love just saying good
morning just helping people
it's crazy doing DMS in the morning on
my Instagram and spending eight seconds
making a video for somebody and then
seeing the reaction like you don't know
how much this video meant to me that you
would send us it's coming to me at the
right time today I really needed that
encouragement
took me eight seconds to do but it
changed somebody's life right is that
going to help me grow my subscribers or
comments or Revenue no right but it
feels really good
and you need those little y's so what
are the things that
are connected to your big mission
but are really small but it's a it's an
individual that you can help one person
that by you helping one person today
you've got your little why that can give
you the motivation to keep going
how do we stop sleepwalking through life
right Big Y you're on a big mission that
you're trying to accomplish something
huge step two is a little why we feel
like today is going to matter to
somebody to one human even if it doesn't
accomplish our big mission step number
three is to pay it forward
you know how good it feels to get a
comment to get a video to get a
personalized message for somebody to
help you out
Pay It Forward especially to small
creators my ask for you would be if you
if there's somebody that you follow
somebody who you who whose Journey
you're following along with maybe it's
your friend who's posting maybe it's
some total stranger who you've found
some of their content
go give them a little love
go get them a review on iTunes go give
them a comment on their YouTube or
Instagram or wherever you're following
them
it means so much
if it's a giant Channel
or someone's been doing it for a long
time you know I don't see all the
comments that come in don't don't leave
a comment on if you I mean leave a
comment on the videos but it doesn't
mean as much anymore as it used to right
because we get so many so we're spoiled
so the big the big creators don't worry
about it you can it's always good karma
that's to spread positivity but if you
had to pick
pick for the smaller ones
because just one person saying I see you
just one person saying thank you just
one person saying this message meant
something to me this just one just one
person
having that belief
is the difference quite often between
them quitting and them following through
your single message today to somebody
is going to be the difference I promise
you for somebody if you did that every
day it will for sure be the difference
for quite a number of people between
them quitting and then continuing on
because you took 15 seconds to send a
quick message to them
so Big Y little Y and then pay it
forward especially to the small creators
we got to get out of the Sleepwalk guys
we we want to feel like we matter we
want to feel like today matters we want
to feel like the work we do matters and
the best way that you can inspire people
you want to help the people around you
you want to help your community you want
to help your family you want to help the
people who might see you you want to
help people the best way to help them is
for you to stop sleepwalking it's for
you to start doing things that matter
it's not for you to just
make an inspirational video
it's through your actions that if you
showed up today and decided that you're
going to remember your big why that
you're going to serve with your little
why that you're going to pay it forward
to other people
when you see the impact that that can
have on their life
it makes you reconnect to why you do
what you do
and if you woke up and did the thing
that made you remember why you do what
you do and you felt it not just words
you're telling yourself but you
genuinely felt it
holy cow look out because life starts to
get really really good the biggest fear
we have isn't failure you're not afraid
of failing the biggest fear we have is
of failing in front of other people
you're afraid of people's judgments the
reason why we stay stuck the reason why
you still are where you are is because
you're afraid of other people's opinions
you have
great ideas inside you you have great
Cliff here watching this video You're
subscribed to this channel you have
great ideas you know you're capable of
more you know you want to serve you know
you want to help
and great ideas are flowing through you
and we shut them off
shut them off because we find a logical
reason why we can't do it right the
logic reasons in our head are well the
timing's not right or I don't have the
gear right on the connections or uh you
know I'm in the wrong country or
whatever logical excuse that we come up
with that's that's listen it's based in
reality it's actually based in fact
because you wouldn't you're a smart
person you wouldn't believe a stupid
reason
so the reasons that we're listening to
are actually based in some kind of fact
but they're still an excuse and
underneath it underneath that reason why
you can't do something is because you're
afraid
you're afraid I'm afraid we're afraid of
taking the next step and the fear
underline that is not the fear of it not
working out it's the fear of it not
working out and who's going to see you
you were so tied up into what other
people think about us that we'd rather
play small for life than actually go off
and accomplish and risk failing in front
of other people we're so afraid of that
that we never go off and
chase our dreams down and you're stuck
in this mental exercise of what you
could do
and then never actually doing anything
my biggest fear of disappointing people
you know it's that's still fear of
judgment it's still fear of I'm gonna
show up and speak in an event and it's
just not going to go well that that
people will
be unhappy with my speech and I put
a crazy amount of pressure on myself and
in my head I think people are here and
if I struggle then the whole thing is
ruined right I remember I was speaking
that for number shards event and uh it
was in Puerto Rico and people are paying
tons of money to be here you know it was
a 30 to 50 000 Mastermind and
everybody's got giant businesses right
these are multi-million dollar
businesses owners who are in the house
and it was a multiple Day event I think
it was a three-day event and I'm I'm
speaking for one of them not even a
whole day I'm speaking I have one I've
got an hour or something of time right
at that event
in my head it's if I suck on stage then
people will freak out and be unhappy and
say this was a total waste of event
we're really I'm a really tiny nothing
part of this event right I mean people
are there to see Brendan burchard the
scene Dean graziosi to see the other
speakers there if any one speaker sucks
I mean if Brendan sucks that's a big
deal because he's speaking for 80 of the
time if I suck for one hour nobody's
really gonna care nobody's really gonna
be asking for a refund but
even though that's the the actual answer
it's not the it's not the thing that's
in my head and that's what we need to
fight that's what we need to fight
because I used to say no to
Opportunities because I was really deep
down just afraid that I would not be
able to deliver
I remember that I used to secretly hope
people would cancel on me
I would I would secretly hope that
interviews would cancel on me that
meetings would cancel on me
um I remember I would book something out
like it's two months in advance right I
don't know if this has ever happened to
you this this makes sense or if it's
happening to you let me know in the
comments
I would book something out that was a
month in advance or two months in
advance and so yeah I'm like that's
exciting I'd happy to do that and then
on the day of I'd look at my calendar
and say oh that's coming up and I would
secretly hope I would check my email I
remember would be checking my email
hoping that that person would cancel on
me to say oh I'm busy or I got sick or
it's not going to work out anymore and
let's reschedule and I remember I check
in the morning and I check two hours of
four and check an hour before and check
half an hour before and check 10 minutes
before like if there was no email then
then I would go ahead and do it
so I'm losing insane amounts of
productivity right like how many times
am I checking my email before this thing
happens lose an insane productivity and
also not actually serving right not
actually living my mission my message
not not actually being proud of myself
for what I'm doing and it
it almost always worked out like I never
had an interview or a meeting or
something where I just massively
underperformed and actually sucked right
that that never really happened but I
was always afraid of it happening
and so I had to teach myself
this is this is what I want to do like
the only thing worse than me not doing
this is is me doing this and canceling
right or them me never doing an
interview and me never doing a meeting
and just recognizing that it was just
fear talking and again the fears of me
disappointing people and failing in
front of somebody else
I'm sitting here filming in in the car
Nina just came back we love you Nina
Nina's uh doing some grocery shopping
and I'm filming here you know in the car
we got the dogs here in the back seat
timo's chilling and this used to make me
afraid you know that look there's a guy
who just pulled up next to me
she's not watching but in my head you'd
be like this guy's watching
you can't be afraid of filming in a
parking lot be afraid of filming uh
walking down the street I'd be afraid of
filming with my sister in the room you
know I used to be afraid of all of that
so what is that
it's just fear of other people's
opinions why am I afraid of this guy
why I'm afraid of that guy I don't know
that guy
right
why am I afraid of him and his opinion
first off he doesn't even care right
he's not even looking at me he doesn't
even care maybe he never even noticed
that I was filming period right so we
think people care they don't care
on the off chance that he actually cares
uh maybe he is judging me and thinks I'm
crazy holding this camera up with with
the tripod in my hand maybe he thinks
I'm crazy great uh if somebody's leading
with that then then they hate their own
life like if somebody's leading with
just negative judgment he's got his own
issues to deal with that have nothing to
do with me or maybe he's inspired maybe
maybe this guy goes look he pulled out
his phone maybe he's making his own
YouTube video maybe he's inspired maybe
that guy is now going to be the next
YouTube sensation let's go
so we assume that everybody's gonna
watch us everybody's only looking at us
and
and we're gonna disappoint and be a
giant failure and everybody's gonna
laugh for me to kill us right like
that's the thought that's that's in our
head where the reality is most people
don't care
most people right like 90 of people
don't even care
five percent of people might judge you
and they were in a really negative spot
themselves and the other five percent
maybe they're inspired by you and they
see that and they go and do something
with their life
but you playing small and listen to that
fear instead of actually taking some
kind of action will always lead to a
negative spot like you know that you
could do more you want to do more you
want to serve on a bigger scale but
listening to that fear
instead is keeping you stuck this is one
of the biggest problems for
entrepreneurs is that you you have all
these great ideas that are flowing
through you right you've got you've got
an endless list of ideas how big is your
list of things that you could do that
you get excited by when you look at them
and then how many are you actually doing
well not very many you're missing the
momentum because at the end of the day
you could write down a list of all these
reasons why it can't work out and and
when the timing is going to be just
right and perfect right I'll start this
on January 1st or start this next month
or next week or Monday or my birthday or
some artificial day you come up with
some reason of when you should be
starting this thing right but if you
actually examined it if you actually
took a little step back and looked at
your goals that you haven't hit that you
haven't started that just remain an idea
and you've never taken momentum on if
you actually took five minutes to step
back from it create a little distance
and look at them and look at your list
of reasons why you haven't started
really it's just fear
and when you can catch that
that's when you make a life-changing
decision
because as long as you are
not chasing down the things that you
want to do because you're afraid of
somebody else's Judgment of you as long
as that is a thing that rules you you
will never win you will never accomplish
anything great and you'll you'll live
life with regret so even now my my
biggest fear is still disappointing
people
and the ongoing challenge is to catch it
and when you can catch it and when you
can know BS
catch it to say I'm just throwing up a
bunch of excuses but really I'm just
afraid when you can catch it
then
summon the courage to go to the
difficult thing summon the courage to
say I'm gonna I'm gonna take this fear
head-on
because as long as that fear runs your
life
you stay stuck
and every time you catch the fear and
you do it because of not just feel the
fear and do it anyway Feel the fear and
do it because of
you start to teach yourself to be a
little stronger a little more courageous
and you move a little bit closer to
becoming the person that you are capable
of being get rid of your 10-year goals
and create a mission instead
I think a lot of people are so worried
about where they're going to be in a
year and five years and 10 years so we
do these goals planning actually you
ever gone through that you ever gone
through a goal plan and exercise goal
said and exercise at events you read a
book says we're going to be in a year
and five years or 10 years
and the more that I've thought about it
the more that I've gone through the
exercise is the more I realized it's not
important
that's not helpful it's not where we
want to be because you don't know what
you're capable of in a five-year period
a 10-year period think about who you
were five years ago take today's date
and subtract five years think about that
person
could you have predicted where you are
right now could the person you were five
years ago have any degree of confidence
is plan a life for who you are right now
this is like there's no way there's no
way not if you're growing not if you're
learning not if you're improving if
you're watching this channel then you're
somebody who is learning and growing and
improving and so you had no idea what
you're capable of five years ago and so
what makes you think that it's any
different now that you can plan for the
next five years the only way that you
can create a 10-year plan for yourself
is if you are not growing and you're in
a really static life you know like if
you're going to be a lawyer and you're
going to work your way up and be a
senior partner at the law firm and that
that takes a certain amount of time cool
you could you could plan that out
that's a pretty boring life
you know chances are if you're watching
this video you don't want that life that
you want to create new and build new and
that requires
being the being flexible to jump off of
your 10-year goals right it's not that
it's wrong to have goals goals can work
they can be motivating but
your goals right now a reflection of who
you currently are
that's the problem whatever goal you set
right now is a reflection of who you
currently are and the more that you are
growing as a human and the more that the
world involves the new technology comes
out new opportunities arise
the longer Horizon you put out the less
accurate it's going to be
and so instead of worrying about having
a 10-year goal replace it with a mission
the problem of a 10-year goal is you
could actually hit your 10-year goal
it's just way small compared to what
you're capable of
and so the answer is have a mission
what's your mission what are you trying
to accomplish like what's the big
problem that you're trying to solve and
then wake up every day trying to attack
that mission as opposed to worrying
about where you're going to be in 10
years this might flip a lot of goal
setting on its head it might flip a lot
of what you've been told or taught or
thought on its head and listen if having
that 10-year goal works for you and is
actually motivating cool keep keep with
it keep going if it's helping you use it
but if you feel like there's something
more or you feel like 10 year goal is
not enough you don't feel motivated when
you look at your 10-year goal from two
years ago it doesn't appeal to you
anymore it's probably why you know
you're you're growing too quickly the
problem is not your goals the problems
that you grew too much the 10-year goal
is great for who you were three years
ago
you're not that person anymore you've
grown too much it's that's that's not a
reason to feel bad that's really feeling
amazing you know you've grown you've
outgrown yourself you've shed your skin
you now turned into the next generation
of you
and So my answer is in Mission what's
the mission what are you trying to
accomplish you know so for me I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
entrepreneurs and you know people don't
believe in themselves people don't
believe in themselves and I don't
believe myself enough you don't believe
in yourself enough nobody nobody you
know walking out here believes in
themselves enough we just we don't
believe in ourselves enough
and I want to I want to solve that
problem and I'm I'm never going to solve
that problem and I wake up every day
trying to solve that problem and why
it's so helpful to have a mission like
that is
because it gives you something to fight
for every day and there's always
something new that can come out that can
help you with that and there's always
opportunities that I think guys the
amount of things that I've seen and that
happened in the past 10 years if you
look at 10 years ago
where was I on YouTube I started in
April 2009 so it was early in on my
career on YouTube I had a couple hundred
subscribers there's no way I would have
said it'd be here
there's no way just with the with the
impact I've had with the people I've met
with the even just the confidence to sit
here guys I would have been so terrified
to sit in a park making a video
terrified of who's watching me who's
judging me who's coming around the
corner who's behind there maybe you know
looking at me and judging me you know
they've been it's would have been
impossible so the person I was 10 years
ago would have never even thought of
this as a possibility
and now it's it's it's normal
it's not a problem
right how quickly that we can grow
and so you come up with a mission it's a
problem you're trying to solve and then
as you develop new skill sets and
improve mindsets and better belief
systems and as you know the market and
Technology evolves and opportunities
arise as you keep going and building
momentum there will be new things that
you can go off and do that you never
thought were possible but it's always in
service of the mission
so how do you find the mission well
that's your purpose for me and your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled the most with is the thing
you want to help other people through
and so I struggled so much to believe in
myself in the early days of my business
and quit like I quit for one day on my
business in worst day of my life and I
just want to make the path a little bit
easier for others how do I keep going
people ask me how do you how do you keep
going how do you keep making content
have you made I don't know thirteen
thousand fifteen thousand I don't know
how many videos I've made it's crazy how
many videos we've done
I only slept two and a half hours last
night it was a really rough night why
get up and keep making content because
I'm on a mission
because this means something to me
whether four people watch this video or
four million people watch this video
I'm hoping that this video in some way
is the video that moves a needle just a
little bit for somebody watching maybe
it's you maybe this is the video that
you decide I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna find my mission I'm
gonna stop creating 10-year goals and
stop over planning over preparing and
overthinking and over strategizing and
over doubting myself and just go do
something like maybe today this is the
video or maybe I make another video
today that accomplishes that like that's
that's my goal that's why I do what I do
that's what gives me the energy to wake
up when
every bone in my body is saying you know
sleep
don't do the difficult thing
and it's easy because I'm on a mission
and so what's yours what did you
struggle with the most as a human
and if you can connect to that
you can think about all the people who
currently are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with
you know you're not done growing you're
not done learning you're still improving
there's still a long ways to go you're
by no means perfect neither am I
but you're a lot further ahead than you
used to be and there's a lot of people
right now who are right now stuck where
you used to be
I didn't know what to do they don't know
where to turn they don't have anybody
who believes in them they don't have any
hope they don't have any strategies they
think they're stocked they think they're
stuck
in your story your message your content
you reaching out you could make the
difference for them
if you actually believe that it's going
to just change the energy with which you
show up and open you up to amazing new
opportunities that again you can't
predict 10 years in advance
so it's a it's a challenge it's a call
to action today
if you love setting your 10-year goals
and it works for you amazing keep going
do what works for you but if you feel
like
you're judging yourself against them if
you feel like they're not working for
you if you feel like you're six months
in and you already want to change it the
problem is not that it's a 10-year goal
the problem is that you have already
outgrown what what you're capable of
you've already outgrown it six months in
a year and
and the thing that you want to outgrow
is the mission
to have a have a goal have a purpose so
big
that you never solve it and you wake up
every day trying to solve it
[Music]
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to watch another top
10 rules of Evan Carmichael check out
the video next to me continue to believe
I will see you there we know we're
capable of more we know we're capable of
helping I know I'm capable of helping
but because you're afraid of saying the
wrong thing because you're afraid of of
letting somebody down because you're
afraid of giving the wrong advice what
ends up happening is